[Music]
so how does it feel to be a part of the
whole and man universe it feels great to
be a part of the Marvel Universe it's a
dream come true for me to be a part of
the Marvel Universe is it really like
Farian yeah and still am like you know
love comic books always have always will
and so did you had any characters just
like a character you were dreaming of
playing I actually got to voice a
character I dreamed of playing in a
movie called Fantastic Four rise of the
Silver Surfer yeah that was my first
four way into the Marvel Universe where
I voiced the Silver Surfer and then
after that I I was just you know I was
just hungry to be a part of the universe
so I you know I had a meeting with the
Marvel guys and they were like mmm maybe
we can you know it's kind of cool yeah I
mean you're going up with Michael
Douglas you guys are going toe-to-toe
it's great I mean I you know like I had
that moment three or four times or is so
good he's just so good
but you two together I mean that's magic
good thank you yeah it is and did you
ever guys ever because I know you're
both method actors so off-camera did you
ever do that you know Toto act like you
were no we actually get along really
great I mean Michael invited me out to
dinner the first day I got there we went
we had dinner we talked about life and
kids and work yeah yeah it was cool yeah
it was great you don't stay in the
method character I know I don't I don't
I wouldn't describe either one of his
being method actors that way somebody
else might but I would you undid No
good actors yeah I would say yeah the
Michael Douglas really good actor
Fishburne pretty good you know you talk
about Michael being this you know iconic
actor but I got to tell you when I got
Paul in here he was talking about like
being so enthralled with all three of
you there between Michelle like you yeah
and he said that he had so many
questions that he wanted to ask you oh
and then he can stop coming up to you
did you notice he was coming up don't
know why he was always hanging around
it's like dude don't you got somewhere
to be like aren't you like the ant-man
like aren't you the star he said he was
like they had to ask you about
Apocalypse Now what else did he ask
he asked about that he asked about boys
in the hood matrix and you know just
fascinating stuff he said he was like a
kid in a candy store yeah it was it was
great to work with everybody really I
mean em and Hannah and Evangeline and
Michael Pena I mean it's just so much
fun so good do you think it was there
the movie is so brilliantly brilliantly
done as far as the comedy do you think
that Marvel did it's a purpose because
after Avengers infinity war we needed
like a little huh here's the thing I
have to say because I'm a huge fan of
both the Marvel comic universe and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they've done
an amazing job of really really bringing
the source material into this moment
right now and I like to give a lot of
the credit for that too you know there's
three or four people you know Kevin
Feige and Luis Esposito obviously
Stanley stand too manly and and then you
know on the acting side I give a lot of
that credit to Robert Downey jr. yeah
cuz he's the tip of the spear and what
he always does really well and has
always done really well is he as Tony
Stark Iron Man he allows you in on the
joke there's always a wink and a smile
going yeah yeah yeah we're gonna save
the world and everything is coming apart
but let's not forget that this is a
comic book based story and we should
have fun yes and they've done that
consistently throughout most of the
movie
certainly in the last five to seven
years of the ten you know there's always
that and so ant-man is a continuation of
that in Paul Rudd and the rest of the
writing staff on ant-man one and ant-man
and wasp did that really really
beautifully and such a really smart and
thoughtful way and I think that's part
of why you know the movies are so
successful I agree
how about that big female component of
this movie first yes yes and then you
got serious errors between the villages
and the lead female yes you know well
let me just say first of all like
Evangeline Lilly as the wasp is
completely badass yeah like super badass
and then Hannah John came in as the
ghost is incredible I mean her opening
moment she is so disarming you think oh
she couldn't possibly hurt a fly or a
wasp right and then you know the radiant
Michelle Pfeiffer this means it's really
cool yeah yeah it's really cool to have
three ladies you know out front just you
know taking charge kicking ass it's
really great
[Music]